,
vous êtes considéré comme
une star de l'art covavavavavavs
au cours des prochains mois
à Montréal. Pourquoi? C'est
parce que vous allez exposer ici
même au Musée des beaux-arts de
Montréal, de février à octobre2e
histoire, pour ceux qui vous
connaissent pas, vous êtes né
en 1980 à Lausanne, en Suisse.
Et pour vous, tout a com
avec l'amour du graffiti. Vous
étiez graffeur. Explications.
(petit rire)
NICOLAS PARTY, artiste visuel
- Oui, tout à fait. En fait,
j'ai commencé à faire des graffs
à l'âge de 11 ans à Lausanne.
Enfin, j'habitais dans un petit
village àté de Lausanne,
au bord du lac. Et en fait,
quand j'étais petit,
j'aimais beaucoup les bêtises
et le dessin et la peinture.
Et en fait, quand je suis devenu
un peu plus grand, adolescent,
j'ai essayé de mélanger
les deux. Donc le parfaitmémémén
amour et la passion de l'art,
c'était de faire des graffs.
- Revenons à cette exposition au
Musée des beaux-arts. Vous
complètement transformé le vieil
édifice avec vos oeuvres.
Qu'est-ce qui est venu vous
chercher, vous, dans le projet?
- Bien effectivement, l'espace
en lui-même m'a énormément
influencé. C'est un espace
classique absolument merveilleux
et fantast y y y y y a des
détails architecturaux, la série
de salles, les différentes
perspectives, elles sont
vraiment incroyables à utiliser.
Donc ça a vraiment été
une énorme chance et un plaisir
extraordinaire, en fait, de
travailler avec cet espace.
ououououous attrape en plein
travail, parce que dans la pièce
d'à côté, vous effectuez
une immense murale, et c'est
une murale en pastel, qui est
votre médium de prédilection.
En 2022, le pastel, pourquoi?
- Le pastel, en fait, souffre
un peu de préjugés à cause de
son histoire particulière, qui
se passe au XVIIIe siècle.
Et en fait, c'était un médium
qui était énormément utilisé
par les femmes,
C'est parce qu'en fait,
vu qu'il était fait en bâton,
on pouvait le faire à la maison
à l'époque au XVIIIe siècle,
il y a... et la peinture
à l'huile demande un atelier,
on doit fabriquer. La peinture,
elle n'existe pas en tube.
Ete e e e e e pastel devient
extrêmement populaire pour
les femmes, qui ont pas
le droit d'aller à l'académie
d'arts. Et en fait, à la
révolution française, il y a
un espèce de "backlash" énorme,
parce que c'est un mouvement,
quand même, très masculin et, er
artistiquement et culturellement
par rapport au mouvement rococo,
effectivement, qui adore
le pastel. Et ça, vr
ça donne un frein et ça casse,
en fait, cette évolution
du médium, elle presse depuis
ce moment-là, en fait, le médium
souffre toujours de ces âpreries
qui sont plutôt liées
aux hobbys, comme ça, quelque
chose de pas sérieux, même
avurururururururs un petit peu
frivoles, et tout ça, alors
qu'en fait c'est, vraiment,
un médium extraordinaire, qui a
des couleurs très pétantes,
qui a une versatilité...
qui est très versatile en fait
dans son utilisation.
- Vous avez un vif intérêtpopop.
Visiblement, vous êtes inspiré
par Georgia O'Keeffe, la peintre
américaine, mais aussi,
on ressent un petit
de Picasso dans votre travail,
un peu de Dali, tout ça en même
temps. Qu'est-ce qui vous
intéresse autant dans le passé
pour mieux voir le futur?
- Ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
dans l'art, c'est justement
sa capacité à traverser le temps
et anananananananans le temps,
en fait. Une oeuvre d'art
n'est jamais contemporaine
ou ancienne. En fait, une oeuvre
d'art est toujours de qualité,
peut traverser le temps.
Et on peut voir un peu toujours
un sujet, en fait, présent dans
une oeuvre d'art qui a été créé,
c'est un des thèmes de
l'exposition, c'est de revisiter
l'idée du paysage et de
notre relation à l
des peintures qui sont des fois
complètement, entre guillemets,
anachroniques par rapport
au monde dans lequel on vit.
Mais l'art, contrairement
à la science, typiquement,
nous permet en fait vraiment
de voyager dans le temps, de
se retrouver face à
qu'on peut vraiment... avoir des
interrogations très courantes
et très contemporaines avec des
objets qui sont très anciens.
- En fouillant dans
votre catalogue, j'ai vraiment
été interpellé par le regard
de vos personnages. Qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent dire?
- Pour moi,
un petit peu la... ils ont
le regard un peu peut-être d'un
portrait qui est effectivement
perdu dans l'espace. Des fois,
je l u u u u u u u u u un filtre
ou la couche de maquillage
qui reste sur une personne.
Et c'est comme si, en fait,
vraiment, c'était la surface
d'un visage qui nous regardait
par l'intérieur du visage.
Donc en fait, on est un peu
traversés, mais ça nous traverst
transparents ou en fantôme. Et
il y a quelque chose d'un petit
peu, effectivement, énigmatique
qui fait presque un peu
à la manière de ces portraits
sur Instagram avec les filtres
qui nous regardent et on sait
plus trop si c'est des vraies
personnes ou des personnes
complètement digitales.
Donc j'essaie peut-être un peu
d'avoir ce type d'interaction
avec l
- Vos oeuvres valent leur pesant
d'or. D'ailleurs, 3 millions $
pour une de vos toiles chez
Christie's à l'automne dernier.t
à l'argent?
- Euh... disons que je le vis
bien dans le sens que
ça me perm
une vie qui est agréable et
qui est pratique. C'est jamais
facile pour un artiste de se
soucier constamment de payer son
atelier, de payer le matériel,
d'avoir un autre travail à côté
de son travail d'artiste. Donc,
c'est clair que de vendreererert
tout simplement de... d'avoir
une vie qui est beaucoup plus
aisée et facile et qui est
forcément beaucoup plus
à avoir qu'une vie où on doit
toujours se battre payer
le loyer. Donc, c'est
une chance extraordinaire.
- Nicolas Party, je vous ai
dérangé en pleine création, v vr
à vos pinceaux et à vos pastels.
Merci beaucoup!
- Merci bien!